this is roman abramovic russia's most
famous oligarch he's the owner of the
chelsea football club owns a fleet of
super yachts and he's one of the newest
additions to the international sanctions
list roman abramovich has been hit with
financial sanctions by the european
union roman abramovich has now been
added to the uk sanctions list but
that's not really the most interesting
thing about him
you see roman is a self-made man who
worked himself out to be one of russia's
richest and most respected men back when
russian president boris yeltsin decided
to step down roman abramovich was
actually one of the first people to
recommend vladimir putin take his place
since 1999 when roman helped form his
first cabinet as prime minister putin
and abramovic have been almost
inseparable
roman became one of putin's closest
friends and it was so far that their
relationship was described as one
between a father and a son
roman was there for putin through all
the ups and downs when putin needed to
choose his replacement in 2007 roman
helped him decide on a man named
mimbidev
for a lack of a better description roman
was putin's ride or die until putin
tried to kill him
just this year ibramovic was in kiev to
join peace talks between russia and
ukraine soon after the meetings roman
and two other people who attended
started feeling sick roman couldn't see
his eyes turned red and watery his skin
started peeling from his face and hands
he was in excruciating pain and he had
to be evacuated to turkey for treatments
the cause probably a poisoning by
russian operatives
and for a man like abramovic the only
person who could have given this order
was vladimir putin
but how did they get to this how did
roman go from being putin's closest ally
to being on putin's hit list how could a
father poison his own son
to understand this we need to dive a
little deeper into a story
this is roman abramovich the most
notorious russian oligarch
[Music]
to stay afloat the russian government in
the 90s ended up taking lows from
russian oligarchs and ended up getting
screwed and it's the same story for
people too being buried in credit card
debt is a great way to stay poor because
most people are only able to pay off the
interest every month leaving them in
debt forever and currently credit card
debt in the us hit an all-time high this
month so if you're in credit card debts
don't you wish you could get a loan at a
way lower rates and use that cheaper
loan to pay off your high interest debts
so you only have one single monthly
payment with a clear payoff dates
letting you escape from this vicious
cycle once and for all well that's where
upstart comes in upstart is a quick and
easy way to get a personal loan online
that helps you pay off your high
interest debts over 1.8 million people
have already used upside to pay off
their credit card debt consolidate high
interest debts or even fund their
personal expenses upstart gives you a
loan that only requires one fixed
monthly payment with a clear payoff
dates so you always know exactly how
much you're paying and for how long
what's great about upstart is that it
considers factors other than just your
credit score they look at your income
employment and other information to get
you a smarter rate for your loan your
loan offer could be anything from one
thousand to fifty thousand dollars and
you can check your rate in minutes
without impacting your credit score once
you accept a loan offer you could get
access to your funds in as little as one
business day don't wait and check your
rate today at upside.com jake that's
upstart.com jake to check your rate
today don't forget to use my url to let
them know what sent you loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com jake thanks to upstart for
sponsoring this video
roman abramovich wasn't supposed to
become a billionaire by the time he was
3 both his parents had died his mom was
a music teacher and his dad a low-level
civil servant so roman was shipped off
to live with his family in the cold gray
remote north of russia he had no money
no parents and he was never great at
school his future didn't look promising
but roman did have one thing going for
him his entrepreneurial spirits
every couple years someone comes around
who just seems to have something no one
else does no matter how bad their
circumstances they just don't give up
and find thousands of ways to force
their way to success roman was one of
them
when he was 16 he dropped out of school
and started selling used card tires and
car parts back in soviet russia private
businesses were outlawed but roman
didn't care he was making money in the
black markets and even though it wasn't
much it was his beginning a few years
later roman was conscripted into the red
army anyone else would have accepted
their fates and given up on their dreams
but not roman he decided to put his
business sense to good use started
selling stolen gasoline to the units of
the army he worked with by the time he
got out he has saved enough money to
start another black market business
selling perfume which was also illegal
in the ussr
perfume eventually led roman to selling
rubber ducks rubber ducks led into
manufacturing plastic toys for kids in
america the idea of starting a rubber
duck empire sounds laughable at best but
back in soviet russia where people
didn't have access to anything the
government thought was a luxury
businesses like these were in high
demand from selling dollars he moved to
investing his hard-earned money into pig
farms literally bringing home the bacon
in soviet russia this was big stuff for
a 20-something year old and within just
a few years roman made the job from pig
farms to oil and that's where things got
really interesting
in 1992 at just 25 years old roman
abramovich was arrested he had used fake
documents to get 55 tankers of diesel on
a train re-routed to latvia where he
could sell them roman has stopped the
train himself and made the conductor
change the destination
sure he was arrested and had to pay most
of the money back in the end but it just
goes to show how industrious young roman
was
he knew he wasn't made to spend the rest
of his life selling perfumes or kids
toys and just a little later he got his
shot at billions
[Music]
[Music]
this is boris barazowski a russian
oligarch who eventually got on putin's
bad side fled to england and committed
suicide but back in 1995 boris was still
a widely successful russian businessman
who owned a national car dealership and
ran a state-owned car manufacturer
berozowski was also good friends with
boris yeltsin the former president of
russia no one knows exactly when or how
berozowski and roman met but the two
immediately hit it off through boris
roman abramovich had found his way to
the adults table this was where
billionaires were made and he was about
to be one of them around the same year
boris and roman started working together
president yeltsin created a new oil
company called simnift since boris and
roman were so close to the presidents
president yeltsin appointed them as top
executives in sydneyft never dreaming
about what they were about to do 1995
was a busy year for the russian economy
only four years after the fall of the
soviet union the government was in
serious need of cash and so the loans
for shares program was born here's how
it worked the government would put up a
specific amount of shares in state-owned
companies as collateral for a loan
bankers and political insiders would
then give the government money in
exchange for those shares if the
government couldn't pay back the loan
the lenders would keep the shares for
themselves obviously the government
never made enough money to buy those
shares back so instead the lenders kept
their stakes in the companies and some
even took over the businesses completely
after buying out other shareholders it
was russia's very first fire sale and
roman and berozowski wasted no time
taking advantage of it berozovsky had a
lot of friends in high places and now
with the opportunity of a lifetime
before him and roman he put them to good
use in early 1995 a russian minister
suddenly orders 137 million dollars of
taxpayer money to be transferred into an
account at a specific russian bank a
little later that very same bank lends
roman abramovich the money he and
barozovsky needed to take over the oil
company's sid nifts using the loans for
shares program roman and berozowski bid
250 million dollars for control of
sievenifts the company was actually
worth billions but roman and berozovsky
knew just how to trick the government
into taking the deal they even paid
president yeltsin's bodyguard 10 million
dollars on the side to make sure the
deal goes through and it does suddenly a
28 year old was in control of a
multi-billion dollar oil company by the
time he sold his stake in sieventh in
2005 just 10 years later the government
had to pay him 13 billion dollars
he had played the russian government out
of billions and it didn't go unnoticed
because just four years after taking
over sidneth russian lawyer yury
skuratov launched an investigation
against roman and berezovsky
unfortunately for the lawyer he forgot
who the two oligarchs were friends with
president yeltsin within days after the
investigation is announced someone
leaves a sex tape of the lord to the
press he immediately gets fired in the
investigation it disappears into thin
air by the time vladimir putin takes
power roman abramovich is a regular in
the political inner circle he's also in
the perfect position to create his own
direct connection to the new russian
presidents
[Music]
what do you get when a group of massive
aluminum companies all run by powerful
oligarchs are all vying for control of
the industry in the lawless early years
of russia
you get literal war russia's aluminum
wars were bloody like people actually
getting killed over the aluminum
business in roman's own words every
three days someone was being murdered
back in the early 2000s there were about
three or four major aluminum smelters
and processors all trying to find a way
to take over the entire industry and
like true gangsters they all tried to do
it by taking out the other side every
few days a different oligarch ceo or
executive would be killed in his home or
on his way to work everyone was trying
to send the other side a message but
none of the companies wanted to give in
or emit the feats things got so rough
for workers in these companies that by
early 2000 one giant aluminum smelter
krustnayak was in chaos workers were
striking sellers wanted out and it
seemed like the company was just about
to go under just what the other
oligarchs wanted but in comes roman
abramovich there to buy the company to
add to his billions for years the only
way rival aluminum companies could
consolidate was by killing each other
until someone gave up but what if there
was a more peaceful way what if the
biggest aluminum companies merged then
the wars could stop and the new
conglomerate would have a complete
monopoly over the industry and that's
exactly what roman did he used putin's
influence to get another famous oligarch
oleg deripaska to come to the table and
together they created russian aluminum
the world's third largest aluminum
company at the time roman was just 33
years old if he had been rich before he
had now officially reached oligarch
status and it was time to enjoy his
billions
[Music]
roman wasted no time spending his
hard-earned billions he bought the
chelsea football club in 2003 just
because he liked football he spent
millions developing the club and team to
become one of the best in england and
his love for real estate and yachts
meant even more spending he owns a 15
bedroom mansion in london that cost him
nearly 120 million dollars he bought up
three townhouses in manhattan's upper
east side which he planned on turning
into one massive home he's also the
owner of abramovic's navy the nickname
given to his fleet of yachts yes a fleet
he has almost never owned less than
three super yachts around the world in
2008 his net worth peed at 23.5 billion
dollars making him the richest man in
russia for roman it seemed like there
was no end to his influence with putin
he had gone from poor orphan to a
billionaire that putin treated like his
own son nothing could ever go wrong but
then
[Applause]
russia invades ukraine
at first roman thought that he could
avoid the sanctions that hit almost
every other oligarch after russia
invaded ukraine for almost a month he
watched in surprise as all of his old
buddies got their yachts seized and
their homes emptied week after week he
waited to hear his name on the sanctions
list but they didn't come apparently he
wasn't seen as a threat for oligarchy
billions of dollars in assets in both
america and the uk the news couldn't be
any better so roman decided to do
everything he could to stay on england's
good side even if it meant making a show
of attending peace talks with ukraine
maybe if the world saw he was trying to
help resolve the war they would be
contempt with letting him keep his stuff
but in putin's eyes this was a betrayal
that couldn't be forgiven you see when
roman flew to ukraine in early march to
attend peace talks he had not gotten
putin's permission perhaps he thought
his father sent bond with the president
would keep him safe but apparently not
putin had no mercy the day after the
peace talks obramovich suddenly got
deathly ill he couldn't see he was in
constant pain but thankfully he survived
if putin didn't want him dead yet this
was definitely a warning to keep his
nose out of state issues roman probably
assumed that almost dying for his love
of peace would be enough to stop the uk
from sanctioning him obviously he wasn't
on the side of war so he should be able
to keep his yachts in houses right wrong
because less than a week after the
poisoning roman was left with sanctions
just like everyone else his plan had
failed but here's the thing roman either
didn't get the warning from putin or
he's really desperate to get off the
sanctions list because a month after
getting poisoned in kiev he's back in
kiev again for round two who knows what
putin has in store for roman this time
i don't know about you guys but i found
this story super fascinating and if you
enjoyed it my name is jake and we make
documentaries on money power and crime
multiple times a week for free so make
sure you click the subscribe button
below and if you want more documentaries
that are too controversial to be posted
publicly click that join button below
there's a refund policy too so if you
join and you don't like it you can
always email me and i will personally
refund you the money that's going to
wrap it up thank you so much for
watching stay dangerous out there and i
will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you